barbara pompili la ministre de la
transition écologique s'est rendu ce
lundi matin à bonnières sur seine dans
l'entreprise skytech objectif annoncé la
nouvelle stratégie pour la recyclabilité
le recyclage et l'incorporation de
matériaux recyclés du programme
d'investissements d'avenir
un programme qui finance des projets
innovants elle a d'ailleurs annoncé de
nouveaux investissements scellier agathe
son gros a suivi et la conférence de
presse je suis heureuse de vous annoncer
que le gouvernement va engager
370 millions d'euros de nouveaux fonds
paya pour cette stratégie et c'est un
effort sans précédent cette stratégie
elle porte sur 5 matériaux que nous
utilisons au quotidien les plastiques
les matériaux composites
les textiles les matériaux stratégiques
et les papiers et cartons
cette stratégie inédite doit nous
permettre tout d'abord de développer le
recyclage des matériaux stratégiques
ce dont la transition écologique a
besoin et notre ambition c'est de
disposer d'ici 2030 des capacités
industrielles pour recycler 100 % des
batteries de véhicules électriques
arrivant en fin de vie en france
[Musique]